E
PRESIDENT GRO MORE UNPULAR.
INING MEOW IS LOUISIANA
SENATOR JOHNENNEDY.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TIGHT.
WE KNOW THATHINA H A
RECORDING D A TRANSCRIPT OF
ALL OF THE CALLS.
JU AS TRUMP RELSED THE CALL
TO VOTE UKRAINIAN PRESIDE,
WHAT H TO BE DONEERE GIVEN
THE GRAVITY  THE SITUATION?
>> WELL, FIRST, LAURA JT ONE
FO OF VIEW.ROSES ARE RED
POLITIL MOB IS FA.
WASHINGTON WEDNGS ARE JUST
FUNERALS WITH CA.
I KN PSIDENT BIDEN H SAID
HE WL STAY BEHIND ANDTANDS
HIND GENERALILLEY.
AND MAY THAT IS TRUE FOR THE
SHORT-TERM.
I WILL GIVE YOU EVE ODDS THAT
EVENTUALLY T WHITE HOUSETHWS HI.
BECAUSE THE ITE HOUSE
DESPERATELYEED SOMEONE BESES
PRIDENT BIDEN ON WHI TO
BLAME.  PAR - T STUNNING
INCOMPETENCE INFGHANISTAN.
TO ANSWER YO QUEION, EVEN
DUCT TAPE FIX STUPID.
IF GERAL MILLE HADHESEWO
OCSIONS WITH THE COMNIST
PAY OF CHINA, HE IS A SMOKEDTUR.
AND HE OUG TO BE.
IF GENERALILLEY HADHESE TWO
MUTATIONS WITH THE CMONEST
PARTINGF TRY TO AND IF IN THE
FUTURE HE WISS TO COMMENTN
AMERICA'S TIONAL SECURITY CAN
HE SHOULD RAE HIS HAN ANDUT
IT OVEHIS MOUTH.
AMERICA IS NOT MYANMAR.
AMERIC IS NOT GNEAIG
-- GUIA.
IF IT IS TRUE,ENERAL MILLE
BROKE THCHAIN OF COMND BUT
MUCH WORST.HEROKE THE RULE OF CN
CONTROL OF THE MILITAR
PAR ANDVERY DEFENDER DEMOCRA
OR REPUBLICAN, OF CONSTITUTIOL
VERNMENT SHOULD BE OUTRAD.
WE HAVE DECIDED.
>> Laura: LETE JUMP IN HERE.
SENATOR MIKE POMPE ANDORMER
DNI RADCLIFFE IICATED THAT
THEY WERE NO AWARE OF THISALL
ANIT DID NOT G THROUGH
REGULAR ORDER.
IFOU'RE GOING TOTART DOING
FREENCE FOREIGNOLICY TO THI
EXTRA ESTE WAS NOT AWARE OF
THIS.
AND ALSO W NOTWARE OF ANY
PENDING CORACT THAT THE
LIMITATIONAS GOING TO LAUNCHWIL.
SO WHAT WE KNOW IS HE D HAVE
ESE ARE FUN CONVERSIONS.
IS THA NOTNOUGH REGARDLESSF
EVEN T CONTENTS OF T
CONVERSATIONS.
I THINK HE IS QUIBBLING ABOUT
SOME OF E LES.
ISN'THAT ENOUGH THAT H HAS TO
BECAUSE OF THE CLE AND
PRESENT DANGER THAT HE PRENTS
TO THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW?>> WELO
T GET TO HAVE THEIRWN
PERSON FOREIGN POLICIES.
AND IHINK THEENERAL H
CONCEDED THA HE DIDAVE TO
COMMUNIST PAIES.HE CHINESE
WE ND TO SEE E-TRANSCRIPT AND
THE WHITE HOUSEEEDS TO RELEASE
TH TRANSCRIPT.
THEY DON'TEED TO RELEASE IT A
CLASSIFIED STING.
THEY ND TO RELEASED IT IN AN
UNCLASSIFIED SETNG WITH AS
MINIL NUMBER OF REDUCTIS AS
POSSIBLE.THIS IS SERIO.
THIS I MORE THAN JUST
INSUBOINATION.
AS A PEOPLE,E HAVE DECIDED
THAT WE WANTO MAIAIN A WALL
BETWEEN OUR COANDER-IN-CHIEF
WHOUST B DISABLING.
IT IS THE PSIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO W DY
ECTED, A WALLETWEEN THE
PRESIDEN AND A MILITY PAPER.
AND THERE'S REASON FOR THA
BU D'T LOOK AT -- G LOOK AT
MYANMAR.
GOAT LOOK AT GUINEA RIGHTOW.
THERE E MITARY COUPS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
>>aura: I WANT TO GET YR
REACTI TO THIS COMMENT BY THE
SPESMAN AT THE NTAGON.
WATC
>> WHEN THE CHAIRMA ORHE
SECOND-RATENTERACT WITH THEIR
COUNTERPARTS, IT IS A FCTION
OF THEIR JOB.
TH HAVE TO  THAT.
IS EVERY SINGLE INTERACTION
WRITN DOWN AND CENT IN AEMO?
PROBLY NOT
>> Laura THEY REALLY WT US
TO BELIEVE THATHERE I KNOW
RECORDS AT ALL, NO-NOS, OFMILLEA
AND OTH FORGN COUNTRIES
WE ♪♪
E-TRSCRIPTS OF THE CALL.WAS OUR,
NO TRACRIPT?
THEY WE TAPINGIKE FLYNN,
WEREN'T TY?
>> YOU KNOW, GOOD YING TO
GUYS.
THE NSA THEY DOT HAVE.
THE CIA HAS IT.
WE NEED TO SEE THTRANSCRIPT.
>>aura: YOUR PRECTION THAT
EVEN THOUGH THEY SM SO MIKE
DUAN TODAY.
ABT MILLEY CONTE THE
PRESSURE IT LL SY ON FROM
YOGUYS IN THE SENATE TO
McCONNELL,  CETER
AND THAT WILL BE ENOH TO
DEPRESSION AFFTS PUBLIC TT
IS YOUR PRECTION?
I COULD BE WRONG.
JUST THINK IIS A PRACTICAL
MATTER.YOU CAN N BUT YOU CAN'T .
FROM THE STUING INCOMPETEN
OF AFGNISTAN.
>> Lau: WE HAVE 13OLDIERS
DEADN AFGHANISTAN.
NOW WHAT W FIRED.>> T DAMAGE DOR
FOREIGN POLICY, T THE AMERICANS
LEFT BEHIND.
THATS GOING TO TAKE YEAR TO
TRY TO TOOK REPAIR.
I THINHE WHITE HOUSES
LOOKIN FOR SOME ONE ON WHICH TO
BLAME THIS A GENERAL MILLEY IS
ERE.
I'M T SAYING I AGREE WITH HIM.
I THINK EVENTUALL THEY WILL
PUSH HIM IN FRONOF T